you have a trump ally
by the name of matt
brainard
who says that they're going back to the
capitol he appeared on steve bannon's
podcast last week where he said quote as
we continue to raise the profiles of
these individuals talking about the
people who were arrested in the capital
riot it makes it harder and harder for
the left's phony narrative about an
insurrection to stick
we're going to push back on the phony
narrative that there was an insurrection
and they have
scheduled a justice for j sixth rally
in dc
for september 18th september 18th is the
date that he gave
on steve bannon's podcast
now he says that he has gone through
he's gotten this whole thing approved
according to what he said during this
interview
this is a planned rally that is going to
take place he also says he totally has
lawmakers
signed up that are gonna you know come
and speak at this little event of course
he won't tell us who they are yet
but you know if i had to make a guess as
to the kind of people that would speak
at this
uh perhaps of mo brooks jim jordan matt
gates marjorie taylor green lauren
bobert
those kind of seem like the folks that
would be drawn to an event like this of
course time will tell he again has not
released their names he says they will
once they're totally confirmed to the
event but folks we now have a date
we have a date
of when they're going back to washington
dc september 18th
that's the day that they've planned
and this is supposed to be just the big
rally to raise awareness
about the
conditions of the people who were
arrested but here's the other part of
this story folks we have seen both matt
gates and marjorie taylor green and i
believe jim jordan was with him as well
make a spectacle of themselves as they
always do trying to go into the jail
where some of these january 6th
defendants are being held
now they didn't have pre-clearance they
didn't have an appointment they showed
up with a film crew knowing they were
going to be shoved away
because you can't just do that and then
they tried to use that as some kind of
justification that oh obviously the
conditions these people are being held
in are so terrifying they won't let us
in
there is no evidence at
all
to suggest that any of these individuals
are being treated inhumanely or unfairly
while they're waiting in prison okay
no evidence exists
to suggest any of that
so let's get that very clear right now
the people pushing that
are the ones who i guess have a vested
interest
in getting people to think
that bad things are happening to these
individuals because i don't know maybe
they get to have more people show up at
their rally
if they think that these people are
being held in inhumane conditions or if
that they're somehow being treated
unfairly but again don't get sucked into
those lies because there is no evidence
to suggest that any of this is actually
happening it is a political talking
point it is a political stunt it is pure
theater
so don't buy into it
but what we do obviously have to be
concerned about is last time we had a
gaggle of these folks show up in
washington dc
it ended in the january 6 capital riot
now you can call it a riot if you want
you can call it an insurrection you can
call it a failed coup call it whatever
you want you know terminology we can
quibble over all day long and it's a
pointless conversation the fact of the
matter is these people showed up there
on january 6th broke into the capital
smashed windows broke down doors
multiple people on both sides the police
officers and the individuals who stormed
the capitol dead from this
we don't need another show like that
we don't need something like this to
happen again so i hope the authorities
are taking this seriously not to go down
there and bust them up if they've got
permits for it hold your rally
it's going to be filled with lies and i
hope nobody walks out there actually
thinking anything you're saying is true
but if you've done the due diligence if
you filed the paperwork you have a right
to assemble and nobody should infringe
upon that
we just got to make sure that dc is
protected and that these individuals
don't once again fall victim to the lies
of charlatans who know what they're
saying is false oh and by the way
always happen to disappear
before things get too rowdy
you know so they can say oh i wasn't
even there for that i was just there for
the rally yeah they throw you folks
under the bus
remember that if you travel to dc for
that september 18th justice for j6 rally